ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen das
Personal soll sich auf einen tragischen
Kampf gegen Corona einstellen das
fordert ein Krankenhaus in Shanghai und
fordert von seinen Mitarbeitern höchsten
Einsatz in den nächsten Tagen denn China
hat quasi alle seine Beschränkungen
aufgehoben und jetzt breitet sich kobit
19 ungebremst aus und bringt das
Gesundheitssystem an seine Grenzen
experten befürchten mehr als eine
Million Tote die Welle trifft viele
Kliniken offenbar unvorbereitet und die
Lage könnten noch schlimmer werden
darüber sprechen wir heute wenn ihr oder
sie Fragen habt schickt sie uns gerne in
die Kommentare wenn ihr uns über Youtube
und Facebook verfolgt oder wenn ihr oder
sie die ZDF heute App nutzen an die
eingeblendete E-Mail-Adresse ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de mit dabei in der
Sendung ist später ein Epidemiologe Herr
Professor hajozep aus Bremen und unsere
China Korrespondentin Miriam Steimer ist
uns zugeschaltet live aus Peking und ich
betone das Live denn bei Miriam ist es
jetzt 2:30 Uhr mitten in der Nacht danke
dass du extra für uns aufgestanden bist
und unsere Fragen beantwortest Miriam
wie ist die Lage aus deiner Sicht im
Moment
ja das ist gar nicht so einfach zu
beantworten es gibt glaube ich
verschiedene Wahrheiten es gibt einmal
die offiziellen Zahlen die den man nicht
so richtig vertrauen kann weil hier
nicht mehr wirklich getestet wird das
heißt es gibt keine verlässlichen Zahlen
wie viele Menschen denn wirklich gerade
Corona haben auch was Todesfälle angeht
was Krankenhaus Belastungen gibt es so
eine offizielle Seite und dann gibt es
eine inoffizielle Seite die wir
versuchen herauszufinden über Berichte
von Menschen die uns erzählen wie es bei
Ihnen vor Ort aussieht z.B über die
Situation vor Krematorien war wo lange
Schlangen sind oder wo Mitarbeiter
erzählen dass es den nächsten Termin
erst Mitte Januar gibt oder dass sie
jetzt überschichten Überstunden machen
also es gibt ähm es ist schwierig das
wirklich für das Land zu sagen und es
gibt verschiedene Wahrheiten je nachdem
wo man nachfragt
wir sehen hier gerade auch eingeblendet
Bilder Miriam vielleicht können wir es
auch gleich noch mal zeigen es gibt
viele Tote in Leichen Säcken hier sehen
wir sie noch mal es gibt Bilder aus
völlig überfüllten überfüllten Kliniken
man hat das Gefühl dass die Lage ein
bisschen außer Kontrolle zu geraten
scheint ist das ein ein trügerischer
Eindruck oder kann man das so sagen
also was man auf jeden Fall sagen kann
ist das eine riesige
omicron-infektionswelle durch dieses
Land rauscht und das ist in den Städten
bisschen unterschiedlich hier in Peking
sind wir anscheinend ziemlich früh dran
also es gibt auch dazu keine
verlässlichen Zahlen aber es gibt
Schätzungen das in Peking gerade jeder
zweite etwa an Corona erkrankt ist ähm
das merken wir auch bei unseren Leuten
hier vor Ort das merken wir auch von
Leuten die uns berichten dass in ihren
Unternehmen zum Beispiel 90% der Leute
gerade erkrankt sind es gibt so ein
Spruch den den sie die Leute hier über
wechat weiterleiten der heißt wenn du
niemanden kennst der gerade Corona hat
dann hast du irgendwie Probleme mit
deinem Sozialleben weil es einfach so
viele Erkrankungen hier gibt ich glaube
dieses außer Kontrolle das ist schon ein
richtiger Eindruck das ist allerdings
nicht erst außer Kontrolle seitdem vor
etwa zwei Wochen die chinesische Führung
plötzlich und sehr unerwartet ähm von
Zero Corvette von Politik abgerückt ist
und plötzlich Lockerungen verkündet hat
sondern die Vermutung liegt nahe dass
die Situation schon vorher außer
Kontrolle war und dass das auch mit ein
Grund dafür war also vielleicht muss man
noch mal kurz eine Erinnerung rufen
eigentlich Zelte in diesem Jahr in
diesem Land ja immer die Null Comic
Politik also dass da hieß
Massentests lockdowns für ganze Städte
oder wenn wenn auch nur ein ein
corona-fall gefunden wurden
kontaktverfolgung für jeden einzelnen
Fall und auch
staatliche Quarantäne auch
kontaktverfolgung aller Kontakte dieser
Person also dieses ganze System
scheint schon nicht mehr funktioniert zu
haben weil es einfach schon zu viele
omikonfälle gab im Land also das ist
nicht erst seit den Lockerungen so
sondern die aktuellen Zahlen lassen
vermuten dass das auch schon vorher
außer Kontrolle geraten war und diese
Lockerungen gibt es seit du hast es
gesagt zwei Wochen damit ist die Frage
von h.b auch beantwortet denn der oder
die Userin hatte gefragt hat wann sind
denn die Corona Regeln gelockert werden
danke für die Frage und wie gesagt das
ist die Antwort und jetzt schauen wir
uns gemeinsam mal an Elisabeth Schmidt
hat versucht zusammenzufassen wie die
Situation ist
auf Knien fleht dieser Mann eine
Krankenschwester um Hilfe an doch sie
weist ihn ab Videos wie dieses kursieren
gerade im Netz überprüfen lassen Sie
sich nicht doch auch das Staatsfernsehen
zeigt mittlerweile Bilder völlig
überfüllter Kliniken
junge Mädchen normalerweise kommen bei
uns 100 Patienten pro Tag in die
Notaufnahme momentan sind es 400 die
meisten sind schon älter haben
Vorerkrankungen und befinden sich in
einem wirklich kritischen Zustand die
winterwelle trifft das chinesische
Gesundheitssystem mit voller Wucht gut
138.000 Intensivbetten stehen laut
gesundheitskommissionen bereit pro Kopf
etwa halb so viele wie in Deutschland
die Impfkampagne geht nur schleppend
voran die Weltgesundheitsorganisation
ist besorgt
für die Hälfte aller Menschen über 60
Jahren in China sind gewusstet das ist
einfach nicht das Schutzlevel das ein
bevölkerungsreiches Land wie China
benötigt bleibt die Frage ob in den
nächsten ein zwei Wochen mehr geimpft
werden können
medizinischen kapiton in the coming laut
offizieller Statistik starben diese
Woche in China nur sieben Menschen an
kobit 19 doch immer mehr Krematorien
melden dass sie ausgelastet sind dieser
Bestatter hier in Peking bestätigte dem
ZDF Einäscherung erst wieder Mitte
Januar möglich
es ist gut möglich dass sich halb China
ansteckt die Zahl eine Million Tote
kursiert ich glaube es könnten diesen
Winter sogar zwei Millionen werden china
hat es versäumt seine Impfstoffe an
Omegon anzupassen
Ende Januar stehen auch noch die
Feierlichkeiten zum chinesischen neuer
an der Kampf gegen das Virus er ist ein
Wettlauf gegen die Zeit
ja und Miriam man hat das Gefühl wir
haben es ja gerade schon so angedeutet
dass auch die Regierung damit jetzt
irgendwie überfordert ist oder zumindest
hat man das Gefühl sie ist nicht richtig
vorbereitet es wurden keine
medikamentenvorräte angelegt oder die
Kapazitäten der Intensivstationen
hochgefahren wie kann denn das
eigentlich passieren in einem Land das
bis vor kurzem versucht hat bis ins
kleinste Detail alles perfekt zu regeln
das ist wirklich die große Frage vor
allem auch in einem Land in dem diese
absolute Kontrolle ja so immer nennt
System immer nennt wichtig ist es ist
wirklich eine
kopflose eine völlig unvorbereitete
Lockerungen kann das nicht anders sagen
also es wird total überstürzt und es ist
erstaunlich weil wir haben ja schon drei
Jahre Pandemie und viele andere Länder
haben das schon durch was hier in China
jetzt gerade passiert und die Frage ist
warum hat man eigentlich nicht mehr
davon gelernt das ist so unvorbereitet
ist sieht man du hast es gerade schon
erwähnt an an diesen Sachen also lange
Schlangen vor den Apotheken Fiebermittel
die nicht mehr verfügbar sind heute gab
es ein Video von einer ich glaube es war
eine zahnarztklinik die haben
Fiebermittel so diese kleinen Blister
Sachen auseinander geschnitten also dass
du nur wenige Tabletten dran waren und
die an die Scheibe geklebt und ein
Zettel dazu gehängt das bitte nur
diejenigen die wirklich Fieber haben
sich sowas mitnehmen sollen und haben
sozusagen diese Packung geteilt damit
mehr Leute was davon kriegen können das
ist ein vielen anderen Orten gar nicht
mehr möglich weil einfach nichts mehr
verfügbar ist
Miriam du postest ja auch viel auf
Instagram für die ZDF heute wir werfen
einen kleinen Blick darauf jeder der auf
insta ist kann das sehen hier zum
Beispiel schreibst du oder kann man die
Kamera hast du gefilmt und hast du ein
Post gemacht lange Schlangen vor den
Apotheken und man sieht dass die Leute
in China jetzt quasi nachdem sich der
Start um sie gekümmert hat die ganze
Zeit so ein bisschen auf sich alleine
gestellt sind und der Tenor ist jetzt
jeder muss sich um seine eigene
Gesundheit kümmern wie gehen denn die
Leute damit um vor Ort
ja das ist wirklich ein auch ein Switch
den der auch in der Staatspropaganda
eigentlich nicht zu machen ist und der
bei vielen Menschen auch im Kopf nicht
funktioniert also es gab ja bisher immer
die Ansage der chinesische Staat kümmert
sich um sein Volk die Staatspropaganda
hat gesagt wir machen das besser als
andere Länder hat zum Beispiel in den
Abendnachrichten Todesraten aus den USA
verkündet immer mit dem Zusatz dort
sterben Leute an dem Virus wir machen
das nicht so wir haben zwar extreme
corona-maßnahmen aber die sind dafür da
um die Menschen zu schützen weil in
China Menschen leben wichtiger sind also
das ist das was die Menschen in den
vergangenen drei Jahren gehört haben und
jetzt von einem Tag auf den anderen wird
es umgestellt auf jeder ist für seine
Gesundheit selbst verantwortlich das ist
ein Switch den natürlich viele auch
nicht mitmachen können man sieht es also
zum Beispiel vergangene Woche was
besonders schlimm in Peking ähm da waren
wirklich die Straßen leergefegt also es
sei hier schlimmer aus als zu Zeiten als
hier lockdowns waren also einfach
niemand draußen das liegt daran dass
einer Hälfte erkrankt ist und deshalb zu
Hause ist und aber auch wir von vielen
Leuten hören die ihre Wohnung nicht
verlassen weil sie wirklich Angst haben
vor einer Infektion Angst haben vor dem
Virus das ist natürlich das was die was
die staatsopaganda diesen Menschen in
den letzten drei Jahren auch erzählt hat
wie gefährlich wie tödlich dieses Virus
ist und jetzt wenn man will wenn Sie die
Bilder sehen von überfüllten
Krankenhäusern von der nicht
ausreichenden Versorgung mit
Medikamenten zum Beispiel dann verstärkt
das natürlich dieses Gefühl von da ist
was außer Kontrolle und ich bleibe
lieber zu Hause um mich zu schützen
Miriam hier ist eine Frage von Buddy
über Youtube der oder sie fragt woher
weiß man dass in China Omicron
vorherrscht heißt es nicht dies wäre
eine weniger gefährliche Variante ist es
so dass auch eine weniger gefährliche
Variante wie Omicron eben deshalb in
China besondere Probleme macht weil dort
viele Menschen auch nicht geimpft sind
und weil viele Menschen die gerade alt
sind auch jetzt besonders getroffen
werden obwohl die Variante vermeintlich
nicht so gefährlich ist wie andere
ja also das heißt ja nicht zu gefährlich
dafür aber noch viel ansteckender als
andere Varianten das ist glaube ich das
Problem und du hast gerade schon
angesprochen ein großes Problem ist die
Impfung also man hat in China bei uns
hat man ja zuerst die
Älteren die vulnerablen Gruppen geimpft
in China hat man das umgekehrt gemacht
man hat zuerst die jungen gesunden
fitten geimpft auch mit dieser Message
wir impfen zuerst die gesunden und
fitten was dazu führt dass es nicht
genug also das ist eine Geschlechte
Impfquote gerade bei den älteren gerade
bei den besonders gefährdeten gibt ich
mache mal ein Beispiel von den über
80-Jährigen z.B soll nur 40% gebustert
sein und auch die die geimpft sind bei
denen bei denen bei vielen liegt die
Impfung schon sehr lange zurück und in
China werden nur chinesische Impfstoffe
verimpft das sind alles Vektor im Stoffe
also nicht die Stoffe die auch gegen
Omegon nach Studien wirksamer wären als
die Impfstoffe die hier im Land
verfügbar sind
jetzt werden ja biontech Impfstoffe
eingeflogen für deutsche oder für
Ausländer die in China leben die damit
geimpft werden dürfen könnte das ein
erster Schritt sein dass dieser
Impfstoff auch an Chinesen verimpft
werden kann oder glaubst du das nicht
ja das war so ein bisschen die Hoffnung
das wurde ja verkündet nachdem Kanzler
Scholz hier zu Besuch in Peking war war
bei der anschließenden naja
Pressekonferenz war es nicht es gab auch
keine Fragen sondern eher ein Präsident
aber da wurde das verkündet und da gab
es natürlich schon die Hoffnung
vielleicht ist das ein erster Schritt
also es gab gibt es ja diese
beidseitigkeit also im Moment sind es
nur deutsche in China die jetzt geimpft
werden können sollen mit biontech das
wird gerade wird gerade organisiert
dafür können sich auch Chinesen und
Chinesinnen und Chinesen die in
Deutschland leben mit dem chinesischen
Impfstoff impfen lassen ähm bisher gibt
es aber keine weitere Zulassungen jetzt
auch für Chinesinnen und Chinesen zum
Beispiel die hier leben sondern es wird
explizit gesagt das geht nur für
deutsche Staatsangehörige ab einem
bestimmten Alter zu bestimmten
Bedingungen aber es gibt bisher nicht
diesen Switch dass man sagt okay das ist
jetzt nur der erste Schritt und dann
wird es weitergehen das ist natürlich
die Hoffnung die Fehler haben bisher
können wir nicht sagen ob das wirklich
eintreten wird ist natürlich auch ein
bisschen schwierig in der in der
Argumentation zu sagen das ist jetzt ein
Impfstoff der im Land verfügbar ist der
eingeflogen wird der aber nur für in
Moment tatsächlich deutsche Staatsbürger
dann verfügbar ist das ist ja auch eine
Argumentation die niemand nachvollziehen
kann dazu kommt gerade auch eine Frage
von iche auch über Youtube warum kauft
die Volksrepublik China keine westlichen
Impfstoffe die besser funktionieren ist
das nicht sie nur zentrisch
ja das ist eine gute Frage und die
stellen sich natürlich viele wenn wir
uns erinnern bei der als Kanzler Scholz
hier zu Besuch war war in der Delegation
ja auch bei biontech mit vertreten ich
glaube die Hoffnung gab es schon es gab
ja auch immer wieder das Angebot auch
anderen andere Impfstoffe zu kaufen
bisher hat China das immer abgelehnt und
hat gesagt sie sie entwickeln an was
eigenem es gibt auch immer wieder
Gerüchte dass da noch was kommen könnte
bisher ist es aber nicht der Fall
nun stehen Feiertage vor der türmitte
Januar ich glaube am 22 feiern die
Chinesen das Neujahrsfest ich nehme an
das ist normalerweise eine Zeit in der
viele Verwandten Besuche stattfinden in
der die Leute viel unterwegs sind wie
wird das in diesem Jahr sein
ja das ist tatsächlich also das
chinesische Neujahrsfest ist das
traditionelle Familienfest da haben
tatsächlich auch alle nationale Ferien
also eine ganze Woche frei und das ist
ganz klassisch das Fest wo man nach
Hause fährt wo man zu Familie fährt wo
man dort auch bleibt es gibt ja in China
natürlich auch viele Menschen die weit
entfernt von ihrer Familie arbeiten und
das ist wirklich der Moment wo im ganzen
Land auch Verkehrschaos ist in der Woche
vor dem chinesischen Neujahr weil alle
nach Hause fahren in den letzten Jahren
war das nicht so weil deswegen der
strengen Corona Regeln auch gar nicht
möglich war in diesem Jahr ist es also
zum ersten Mal dass es wieder möglich
ist und viele warten natürlich seit
langem darauf auch ihre Familie
wiederzusehen wenn man sich die aktuelle
corona-lager aber anschaut haben viele
die Angst dass das ein großes super
spider-event werden könnte wenn so viele
Menschen im Land unterwegs sind das
Virus natürlich im Gepäck dabei haben
und vor allem auch vielleicht alte
Eltern besuchen und vielleicht auch alte
Eltern besuchen die eher in ländlichen
Regionen wohnen das muss man wissen dass
es im Gesundheitssystem hier in China
noch einen ein extremes Gefälle gibt
zwischen großen Städten wie Peking oder
Shanghai und eher ländlichen Provinzen
und Regionen wo die
Gesundheitsversorgung sehr viel
schlechter ist
hier ist noch eine Frage Miriam von
b-do know sorry an dieser Stelle ich
hoffe ich habe es richtig ausgesprochen
wie wird es im nächsten Jahr weitergehen
wird die Regierung an der Öffnung
festhalten
das ist wirklich eine gute Frage also
vorhersehen kann man es nicht also die
chinesische Führung ist wirklich eine
Black Box wir versuchen natürlich alle
irgendwie rauszufinden was dort vor sich
geht aber wenn man ehrlich ist wissen
wir nicht was dort passiert im Moment
ist es aus meiner Sicht schwer
vorstellbar dass sie jetzt irgendwie
diese Lockerungen wieder einkassiert
werden und jetzt doch wieder lockdowns
oder ähnliches beginnen kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen wie das funktionieren
soll ich konnte mir aber auch nicht
vorstellen dass von jetzt auf gleich
plötzlich diese Lockerungen kommen
insofern können wir es nicht wirklich
sagen ich glaube dir das entscheidende
wird was passiert wenn es wirklich zu
dieser großen Anzahl von Todesfällen
kommt wie gerade vorher gesagt wird wie
Berechnungen befürchten dann ist glaube
ich wirklich die Frage erstens was
kriegen wir davon mit was kriegt das
Land davon mit oder was schafft die
Führung auch durch staatliche Zensur und
anderes unter dem Deckel zu halten und
dann die Frage wie reagiert diese
Führung darauf denn irgendeine Reaktion
muss es ja geben damit diese diese Toten
diese diese Katastrophe wenn sie denn so
kommt wie sie vorhergesagt wird nicht an
der Kommunistischen Partei angelastet
wird
vielen Dank Miriam Steimer dass du bei
uns in der Sendung warst danke für die
Beantwortung der vielen Fragen und bis
zum nächsten Mal tschüss an dich und Sie
liebe Userinnen und User bleiben
natürlich bitte hier bei uns schickt
weiter eure Fragen und Kommentare und
Miriam hat ja gerade schon beschrieben
von der absoluten Zero Toleranz Politik
bis zur absoluten planlosen Lockerungen
wie sie sich im Moment darstellt was war
da in China los Franziska von
tiesenhausen fast das noch mal zusammen
mit rigorosenmaßnahmen geht chinas
Führung von Beginn an gegen die
Ausbreitung des Coronavirus vor
Massentests
zwangsgarantäne ganze Millionenstädte im
Lockdown China schottet sich ab
wie kein anderer steht
staatschef-shishing Ping für die strikte
nullcovic-politik und er hat damit
zunächst auch Erfolg mit den strengen
Maßnahmen lässt sich das Virus
tatsächlich besser eindämmen als im
Westen für sie der Beweis dass sein
System überlegen ist
doch mit der omicron-variante ändert
sich alles noch nie gab es in China so
viele coronafälle die Führung zieht
Anfang Dezember die Reißleine setzt auf
Durchseuchung statt nullcovit auch weil
es schlicht nicht mehr möglich ist jeden
einzelnen und all seine Kontakte
einzusperren der Hauptgrund für die
Kehrtwende ist aber wohl Chinas lahmende
Wirtschaft wegen der ständigen lockdowns
funktionieren Lieferketten nicht mehr
Ende November die landesweiten Proteste
gegen die strikten corona-regeln die
größten die China seit Jahrzehnten
erlebt hat
doch die überstürzte Öffnung könnte das
Land jetzt ins Chaos stürzen denn gerade
von den besonders gefährdeten älteren
Menschen sind zu wenige vollständig
geimpft
ja und dann blicken wir auf das Thema
noch mal mit medizinischer Expertise und
zwar mit dem Epidemiologen Professor
hajoc vom Leibniz-Institut für
Präventionsforschung und Epidemiologie
in Bremen schönen guten Abend Herr
Professor zip hallo guten Abend ich
möchte gerne direkt mit einer user-frage
einsteigen und zwar fragt Heiko Richter
über Youtube kann man die Anzahl der
Menschen ins Verhältnis setzen bei uns
sieht es nicht besser aus
grundsätzlich dazu wir haben gerade von
Miriam Steimer gelernt die Zahlen sind
schwer belastbar man kann nicht so
richtig einschätzen wie die tatsächliche
Lage ist denn die Zahlen die die
Regierung offiziell rausgibt auf die
kann man nicht so wirklich bauen aber
lassen Sie uns doch die Frage zum Anlass
nehmen darauf zu schauen wie
unterschiedlich die Situationen sich
hier in Deutschland gestalten und die in
China
ja zunächst muss nur mal sagen wir haben
ja auch in Deutschland
nachgewiesenermaßen
40 Millionen
registrierte Infektionen und
wahrscheinlich sogar noch viel mehr das
heißt etwa die Hälfte unserer
Bevölkerung hat sogar eine nachgewiesene
Infektion gehabt und wenn man das auf
China hochrechnet dann selbst bei dieser
Zahl die eben auch noch Unterschätzung
ist würde man an 700 Millionen
infizierte Menschen denken müssen in
China und das ist halt ähm die Situation
vor der jetzt china steht mit der Frage
der ja der Durchseuchung das ist
sicherlich eine ganz ganz schwierige
Situation vor dem Hintergrund das wäre
wie eben besprochen schon auch eine
recht schlechte im Flagge haben im Lande
und jetzt also im Moment eine fast
ungeschützte Populationen viele Hinsicht
und gerade bei den älteren eben im Lande
ist und da gibt es tatsächlich etwas zu
befürchten
zu befürchten dass es viele Tote geben
wird in China bleiben wir zunächst mal
bei diesem Punkt
das ist auch richtig natürlich die
Situation ist einfach so bei hohen
Infektionszahlen gibt es immer einen bei
Omegon zum Glück etwas kleineren Anteil
von Todesfällen und der wird dann in
absolut Zahlen sicherlich im
mehrere hunderttausend vielleicht werden
es auch so wie äh Folge Ding sagte bis
über die Millionen hinaus Todesfälle
werden nicht erinnern nur daran dass wir
in Brasilien in USA in der
bevölkerungsreichen Ländern genau diese
Zahlen gesehen haben und das toppt
natürlich China mit seiner großen
Bevölkerung noch einmal also die
absolute Zahl von Todesfällen die wird
schon bei den erwarteten
Infektionszahlen dann auch in der Folge
diese Größenordnung vermutlich erreichen
wenn ich hier in den Chat gucke dann
sehe ich auf Youtube dass es so einen
kleinen Battle gibt zwischen Team impfen
und Team nicht impfen einen User
schreibt drei Tage Kopfschmerzen hatte
ich als ungeimpfter und ein anderer User
antwortet darauf schön für dich mein
Onkel und meine Tante haben
ommikron nicht überlebt
vielleicht müssen wir diese Debatten
jetzt nicht über den Chat führen wir
laden euch und Sie herzlich ein weiter
Fragen und Kommentare vielleicht zu
diesem Thema China mehr zu stellen und
auch die Chance zu nutzen Herrn
Professor Zep ein paar Fragen zu stellen
so wie das zum Beispiel havato macht der
fragt welche Rolle spielt die Intensität
der Impfstatus und die Anzahl der
potenziellen krankenfälle für die Gefahr
einer kritischen Mutation die dann
wieder zu uns in den Westen überspringen
bringt ja das dürfte aus unserer Sicht
also allen Menschen die Moment außerhalb
ich Chinas leben die die entscheidende
Frage sein es ist ganz klar dass jetzt
erstmal das die die dramatische
Situation innerhalb Chinas läuft und
dort viel Infektionen zu befürchten sind
und das ist jetzt auch schon der Fall
und nun stellt sich tatsächlich die
Frage was ist mit neuen Varianten und
natürlich können Varianten überhaupt
dort entstehen wo es eben zu nach hohen
Dynamik nach hohen
Ausbreitungsgeschwindigkeit und
ja Austausch auch von von
Viren über viele viele Menschen hinweg
stattfinden das ist eine Situation vor
allen Dingen auch bei eben einem noch
nicht trainierten Immunsystem wie es
eben für viele dort ist wo auch neue
Varianten noch mal möglich sind auf der
anderen Seite ist es so dass wir eben
schon Reifen Varianten gesehen haben die
wären montieren andauernd und es wird
auch durchaus diskutiert das Omicron in
der jetzigen Version eben schon eine
sehr hoch entwickelte wenn man so will
Variante ist mit nach hohen
Infektiosität bei insgesamt etwas
geringerer klinischer Bedeutsamkeit das
könnte eben im besten Fall so sein dass
wir es nicht zu einem zu einer
schwerwiegenden Variante eben kommen
lassen oder es nicht dazu kommt und dann
würde eben auch weiterhin die Situation
so sein dass wir mit unseren vorhandenen
Impfungen ganz und den durchlaufenden
Infektionen unser Immunsystem oder für
viele Menschen in der Welt die das eben
schon durch Macht haben ganz gut das
aber die Gefahr besteht sicherlich jetzt
ganz besonders in China
ein Usernamens Fred Klever ist offenbar
nicht zufrieden mit unserer Art der
Berichterstattung und fragt mal wieder
Zeit für Angstmacherei Fragezeichen ist
das aus ihrer Sicht ein berechtigter
Vorwurf also ich glaube erstmal müsste
unser Mitgefühl im Moment sich an die
Menschen in China richten die jetzt doch
jahrelang in einer sehr schwierigen
Situation war durch den Lockdown und
jetzt in der auf eine andere Weise sehr
schwierige Situation kommen nämlich
jetzt sich damit auseinander zu setzen
zu müssen dass ihre Familie und sie
selber erkranken viele Menschen werden
in China die Infektion durchleben und
nicht schwer erkranken und auch keine
keine schweren Symptome haben aber es
bleibt immer ein gewisser Teil der
natürlich wirklich darunter schwerleitet
und das sind wie bei uns auch in der
Zeit natürlich besonders ältere Menschen
mit Vorerkrankungen um die muss es jetzt
gehen es ist ein Spiegelbild dessen was
wir erlebt haben und ob man das jetzt
dramatisieren will oder nicht es ist
halt von der Dimension her jetzt noch
eine sehr besondere Situation in jedem
sind was bisher weitgehend kann man
sagen verschont worden ist von der
Infektion aber eben nicht verschont
worden ist von schweren Folgen der
ganzen lockdown-situation und das da
veränderten sozialen Lage werden sie
gerade vor dem Hintergrund möglicher
neuer gefährlicherer Mutationen dafür
mehr Einreisekontrollen wieder zu machen
mehr zu testen hier auch an den
Flughäfen zum Beispiel
es macht sicherlich schon Sinn im Moment
darüber nachzudenken wenn jetzt jemand
aus dem Land kommt wo gerade wirklich
eine sehr schwere Welle verläuft dass
man dann sagt da braucht man ein gutes
Verfahren um beim einreisen Test zu
fordern oder auch eben auf klinische
Symptome zu testen dass das ist schon
durchaus sinnvoll ist es jetzt
allerdings auch nicht so dass jetzt ein
sehr sehr ruhiges reisegeschehen im
Moment stattfindet international gesehen
wir haben eben über die Situation
gesprochen dass jetzt national innerhalb
Chinas in der nächsten Zeit sehr viel
Reis wird und das ist eher das
Mobilitätsproblem oder die Lage die sich
stellt dass dadurch natürlich die
infektionsausbreite noch mal angefacht
wird international ist es durchaus immer
noch relativ schwierig nach China oder
aus China herauszureisen
der Stelle muss ich noch mal darauf
hinweisen dass Fred clever noch mal
geschrieben hat ich meinte nicht China
ich meinte den Teil mit Gefahr für uns
der unter dem Stream steht also insofern
hatte ich den Kommentar hier in die
falsche Richtung an Sie weitergegeben
danke Fred clever dass sie noch mal
drauf eingegangen sind und in der Tat
haben wir aber auch lange in der
Redaktion darüber diskutiert wie nennen
wir diesen Stream wir versuchen wir
dieses Thema anzupacken denn natürlich
ist es auf der einen Seite primär eine
große Gefahr für die Menschen in China
aber natürlich fragen wir uns hier auch
welche Auswirkungen hat das hier für uns
aber genau darüber haben wir ja gerade
mit ihnen schon gesprochen und tun das
auch weiterhin Herr Professor zip eine
Frage habe ich noch von Uwe schwarz der
hat eine Mail geschrieben china will
seine wildtiermärkte wieder öffnen wie
schätzen Sie diese Maßnahme in Bezug auf
die potentielle Entwicklung neuer
Varianten ein
das dürfte jetzt
speziell für diese Corona Situation
keine so besonders große Rolle spielen
da spielt sich das Geschehen tatsächlich
eher jetzt in dem wird dem Menschen ab
das ist eher ein Problem das
grundsätzlich
dadurch eben zur nordische auch neue
Viren entstehen können das ist glaube
ich ein eher grundsätzliches Problem der
Frage wie man es verhindern kann das
eben Viren von Tieren auf Menschen
überspringen wie gesagt für die
corona-entwicklung derzeit ist das er
relevant
eine letzte Frage Herr Professor CPs
eine Frage von
Entschuldigung jetzt muss ich in mich
hier gerade ein bisschen orientieren in
meinen Kommentaren genau eine Frage die
auch über Mail kam von einer Person
namens B Punkt leicht wird diese neue
corona-welle uns in Europa oder in den
USA nicht so hart treffen wie Anfang
2020 wir haben das ja schon angesprochen
aber vielleicht können Sie es zum Ende
hin noch mal ein bisschen zusammenfassen
ja also das sieht jetzt für mich
wirklich eher wie ein Problem was das
erstmal ganz primär in China jetzt
besteht ist es gar nicht gesagt dass wir
hier neue corona-wellen bekommen wir
haben unsere laufenden allerdings zum
Glück im Augenblick doch gut
kontrolliertem
Ausbreitung von Corona es ist gar nicht
gesagt dass jetzt durch die chinesische
Situation
global neue Wellen laufen das kommt
wirklich auf diese Frage an gibt es eine
gibt es neue Varianten die eben mit
unserem Immunsystem Dinge machen die wir
jetzt noch auf die wir nicht vorbereitet
sind durch die Impfung
Wahrscheinlichkeit stellt sich jetzt gar
nicht so dafür so groß ein aber die
Gefahr besteht dass es das einzige was
jetzt für uns hier relevant ist ich
erwarte jetzt nicht dass wir durch die
chinesischen corona-wellen mit dem
gleichen Virus den wir jetzt hier schon
haben hier noch mal andere Wellen
Ausbreitung sehen werden
vielen Dank Herr Professor HJC für ihre
Einschätzungen Dankeschön dass sie zwei
Tage vor Weihnachten sich noch mal Zeit
genommen haben das Thema ist ja leider
offenbar noch nicht vom Tisch vielen
herzlichen Dank und vielen Dank auch an
Sie liebe Userinnen und User fürs
Mitmachen und Fragen stellen und an
dieser Stelle auch noch mal groß an
Buddy der in den youtube-chat schreibt
vielen Dank ZDF für die hervorragende
Moderation bitte keine Spammer zulassen
danke und an dieser Stelle auch noch mal
vielen Dank von uns hier aus dem Studio
ans Community Management und von uns
allen hier auf dem Lerchenberg frohe
Weihnachten tschüss